so obviously this is a big moment for
you but it's also the end of the year
i'm curious lala what does this next
chapter in this next era look like for
you i'm just you know really about like
self-love and taking care of myself
obviously my son caian is 14 he's in
high school he's my priority but really
just about tapping into me and what do i
like to do and what what do i enjoy it's
always been about everyone else for me
this year i want to kind of make it a
little bit about me does that self-love
include actual love too is that a goal
on your on your list for 2022 who
doesn't want to be in love i mean hey
i'm single
let's see what happens i want to know
this is your son a good wingman or is he
kind of protective of him i know he's
too protective he is not a good wingman
nobody can come next to me when my son
is around at all what are you looking
for in a partner you know just somebody
i could have fun with somebody that i
can laugh with have a good time with you
know just someone that is chill and easy
because that's pretty much my
personality
well i'm happy to be here because you
are so busy and yet here you are adding
fashion designer to your resume how does
it feel so exciting you know i love
pretty little thing i'm so excited to
have an edit with them and a collection
and really just bring my personal
fashion out there and hope that people
love it we love that you're sharing it
with the world because we know you got
the fashion game online thank you this
is actually from the collection so you
can shop pretty little thing to get this
but we're super excited about everything
tell me what was your favorite part of
the creative process or maybe there was
something that surprised you like what
surprised you as you were putting this
together i'm very detail-oriented like
i'm like no that has to be perfect i
don't like how this fits so i just
wanted it to be perfect i wanted it to
fit on everyone how i want it to fit on
me so i took my time with the collection
and super excited with the outcome you
know what's amazing is obviously you got
the crew you guys support each other
with everything you do but i gotta know
who bugs you first for a pr box bugs
before a pr box who's trying to get the
line who wanted the first pick uh so far
i saw a dm from kelly rowland who's like
i gotta have that dress so i gotta make
sure my bestie gets it it doesn't feel
like have that love constantly so
amazing it's the most amazing thing you
know girl power is everything and i have
just an amazing group of friends that
support me and everything is so exciting
kelly's shooting a movie in atlanta
sierra's somewhere with her family kim's
in new york right now everyone's gone
today but we had some fun yesterday